hi guys
this is where our love faces its
toughest test
after this it's just smooth sailing for
the rest of our lives
holly will you marry me
no
marry me holly
no
that guy's got more than he can handle
as it is will you marry me
no
that marriage would be a sham will you
marry me no easy no will you marry me no
that would be hot i would pay to see
that will you marry me holly
no only one that i was kind of worried
about
oh
this is where i fell in love with you
and this is where i ask you to marry me
it started
[Laughter]
marrying me will you be
your wife be coming
evil eyes
[Applause]
thank you so guys guys guys guys
we're moving to colorado
all of us yep
wait what
holly has to go back to colorado i'm
going with her i'm leaving
i want a fresh start
that's awesome that's what i want
okay but
in order for us to make it there can't
be any secrets between us
i didn't do anything i
asked anybody i totally could have and i
didn't at all just listen
remember that casino night about a month
before we were supposed to get married
i kissed jim
what
he told me how he felt and i guess i had
feelings too and we kissed jim came on
to you just listen no i am listening
that's the problem i'm listening don't
yell don't yell
this is over
yeah you're right this is so over
you kidding me pam
come on
they're gonna call the cops
no i paid him off
jet ski money
all of it
i'm gonna kill jim halpert
oh dwight we're so close
just buy us a few more minutes
well they just called me in for an
update so i'll call you right back
okay okay great
oh
hey dwight uh
send in the subs
oh
dunder mifflin this is pam
uh just one moment i'll transfer you
i haven't heard anything
but i'd bet jim got the job
i mean why wouldn't he he's totally
qualified and smart
everyone loves him
and
if he never comes back again
that's okay
we're friends
and i'm sure we'll stay friends
we just we never got the timing right
you know
i shot him down and then he did the same
to me and
but you know what it's okay
i'm totally fine everything is gonna be
totally fine
sorry
um
are you free for dinner tonight
yes
all right
then it's a date
i'm sorry what was the question
hey uh can i talk about something about
when you want to give me more of your
money did you want to do that now we can
go inside i'm feeling kind of good
tonight
i was just um
i'm in love with you
what
i'm really sorry if that's weird for you
to hear but i need you to
hear it
probably not good timing i know that i
just
what are you doing
what do you expect me to say to that
i just need you to know
once
well
i um
i
i can't
no
you have no idea don't do that
what your friendship needs to be
come on
i don't want to do that
i want to be more than that
i can't
i'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
it's probably my fault
not your fault
i'm sorry misinterpreted uh our
friendship
10 minutes ago
no i didn't know what to
say yes i know
um
i don't know mom he's my best friend
yeah he's great
yeah i think i am
um i have to go
i will
listen jim
you